the question with any technology that
has both tremendous benefits and
potential large risks is when and where
are you going to apply it when do the
benefits outweigh the costs I find a
deeply ironic that a country that was
largely populated by people who are
willing to try a new thing and basically
gave up everything they had to try some
new thing to find a better life that 100
200 300 years later we're suddenly
becoming timid we're still on that
journey to find a better life I think
one of the great advantages of our
society is we can empower everyone but
especially kids to actually make a
positive contribution figure out a way
to try out new technologies in a
decentralized small-scale way right now
the Internet has brought everybody
together that means we all swim or sink
together maybe it might make sense to
break up communities or find some way to
foster it sort of experiments
you